Berlin is fertile ground for startups
the central mitad district has even been
called Silicon Alley for its new comms
and IT companies these 70 members
communicate in English on the job and on
their breaks it's the only language they
all have in common they came to Berlin
for many reasons in Mary's home country
Spain youth unemployment is hovering
around 50 percent as a programmer she
would have had better prospects than
most but she decided to try her luck in
Germany anyway we wanted to experience
living abroad and we were looking
through several European capitals and in
the end we decide that Berlin would be
the place and actually the tech scene
sin we are programmers both is very very
hot here and there's a lot of startup
environment so that was our choice
sponsor pay has some 140 employees from
over 30 countries the multinational mix
was intended from the start their
prospective customers are scattered
around the world as our well-trained
software developers and marketing
specialists Toyo Banerjee would hardly
have attempted the project without
foreign employees I think they're quite
agnostic about the source of the talent
in terms of geography goal is to recruit
the best and it sounds pedestrian in
some sense but it's also we've seen that
talent comes from everywhere and we are
open to sort of absorbing talent from
everywhere
with one of the world's lowest birth
rates Germany's population is aging the
Chancellor has made it clear that
Germany needs well-educated immigrants
but to get them German companies have to
compete with foreign firms it must be
our goal to be truly open to young
people from the EU bearing in mind that
in 2025 Germany will have six million
fewer people in the labor force some
members of the government take a
different view the interior minister
would prefer to limit the influx of
foreign workers it's an illusion to
think we can counter the demographic
changes with immigration alone if you
foster the idea of sending our own
people to the welfare lines while we
bring in foreign laborers who do the
same work here for less money is totally
misguided today's migrants aren't just
the manual laborers of the past but
college graduates who could just as
easily find jobs elsewhere
you're missing the fun up commandest we
have to get away from seeing the
immigrants as intruders we have to start
seeing them as an opportunity and
secondly we have to create the
conditions for immigrants to feel like
they're part of this society so we
shouldn't be constantly talking about us
and the others vo and the under
inspection Marty you found a job right
away with the help of a friend she took
care of everything herself language
courses finding an apartment the whole
bureaucracy I didn't find any really
official things about settlement or
things like that I wasn't looking for
that because at first I didn't need that
much I mean we're it like from being
from the European Union is pretty easy
to establish sponsor pay took care of
the formalities for its workers foil
came from India it took him some 12
weeks to get his work permit
there are a lot of processes that are
almost impossible to go through unless
you have a German holding your hand
through those processes so we do have a
very very endearing HR department who
are very kind to help us through a lot
of these processes one obstacle is the
language forms are often only in German
and immigration officials tend to stick
to German as well being able to
communicate in English would be a big
help for many foreign job seekers